bonjour vous êtes là vous allez viens on
va bien rigoler vous savez quel jour
c'est aujourd'hui c'est leur premier
ouais
regardez j'ai pensé j'ai un poisson pour
mettre dans le dos de françois ça va
être drôle
attention le voile a pas d'âme tampa
salon tu m'as l'air de bonne humeur
oui ça va très bien tiens tu as vu
l'oiseau là dans l'arbre je ne vois pas
d'oiseau casini mais si regarde bien
dans l'arbre là où vas-tu et l'oiseau
regarde là là oh non tu le vois pas
casimir je t'assure moi je vois rien ou
bien tu arrives et bien c'est moi qui
suis aveugle bon casimir il faut que je
sauve à tout à l'heure au françois
oui je peux moi aussi sur quoi te donner
une tape amicale dans le dos si tu veux
mais tu ta pas trop fort bon alors quand
le toit bien un mais tourne toi voilà
[Applaudissements]
j'espère que je vienne casser à tout à
l'heure
tout à l'heure à l'heure où loulou je
lis weekes quillard tu as vu ce que j'ai
mis dans le doute françois un poisson
d'avril
ouais mais pourquoi lui accroché après
son d'avril mais c'est le premier
aujourd'hui tu ne le fais pas c'est
monsieur du snav qui me l'a dit c'est
pas vrai si c'est le 1er janvier mais
pas le 1er avril c'est le jour on se
souhaite banane et on a changé d'année
mais oui depuis ce matin je ne me suis
pas aperçu
ça ne se voit pas comme ça tiens tu peux
terminer mon affiche je pourrais au oui
bien sûr
c'est pour souhaiter bonne année à nos
amis il n'ya plus qu'à écrire le nom de
la nouvelle année ah bon c'est facile
alors comment il s'appelle la nouvelle
année évincé facile l'année passée
s'appelait 1974
oui alors tu ne trouves pas le nom de la
nouvelle année bien je ne sais pas c'est
dorothée un unique henri non ce ne sont
pas des noms comme ça on l'année passée
s'appelait 1974
cette année s'appelle 10975 et ça
s'écrit avec des chiffres à d'accord
c'est alors facile
attention âmes on fêtera tout à leur
accord à tout à l'heure bon c'est facile
l'an dernier c'était 1974 donc cette
année c'est de 1974
non c'est pas ça ah qu'est ce que c'est
1789 mais non ça n'a rien à voir
peut-être qu'elle 115 alors non c'est
pas ça non plus
quand j'arriverai jamais dit moi casimir
bonsoir tu as des soucis aux je ne me
souviens plus du nom de la nouvelle
année 1975
ah oui tu veux que je te décris
granollers tu va abîmer mon feutre
écoute comment veux tu que je fasse
alors plus en plus moi je suis pressé
nous tiens j'ai une idée avec l'équipe
alors si tu dois la cub alors vient voir
kazmir 1975 il ya quatre chiffres
alors le premier un super un cube le
deuxième les centaines un deux trois
quatre
5 6 7 8 et 9 d'accord le troisième set
cube 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
voilà les dizaines et le dernier les
unités 1 2 3 4 5 cubes par d'accord neel
975 tu vois comme sommes casimir j'ai
compris il faut que je me sauve je te
laisse merci salaires soit - quatre
chiffres
1 2 3 4 aucun problème premier chiffre 5
cette note 1 c'est ça alors allons-y
bonne année ça 1791
mais non c'est pas ça ok ce que j'ai
fait avant lui c'est celui là qui n'est
pas à sa place c'est le premier celui-là
c'est ça 1579 ben voilà c'est tout je
barsakh 1500
soixante dix neuf voilà mais non c'est
pas ça non plus
alalalala lequel j'ai bougé c'est celui
là qui devait être la voie là mais c'est
ça 5-5 1,9 voilà cette fois c'est ça
mais non c'est pas ça non plus ah non je
vais jamais y arriver quand cet affreux
alors casimir ton affiché permis n'est
pas bon non olala dis donc tu m'as l'air
d'avoir des problèmes
écoute les émirs kazmir si tu n'arrives
pas écrire 1975 tu n'as qu'à écrire
l'autre nom de la nouvelle année ah bon
elle a un autre nom a évidemment tu ne
savais pas non on l'appelle l'année
casimir c'est vrai oui puis ça je le
sais je sais les termes desquels on m'a
dit que j'aimais année casimir ça alors
c'est facile et des histoires
dépêche-toi casimir je vois julie qui
arrive dépêche toi alors c'est fini
c'est un peu qu'est ce que tu fais tu a
gribouillé tout mon affiche mais tu as
mis tout le monde à la place de la
nouvelle année mais c'est françois qui
m'a dit que la nouvelle année ça plaît
aussi l'année casimir enfin poisson
d'avril
oh
wahou